[Music]  okay  this is it everyone  we're here  to have some fun trapping baby  no storm troopers no tie fighters no  threat of annihilation  best vacation ever  summer's about to end and we're all  about to go our separate ways it's a  vacation relax hello there who are you  obi-wan kenobi  what is in this come on out in the sun  come on out and have fun we are on  holiday it's not that kind of holiday  so far  and don't forget my shoulders they  really burn  one never knows how long a moment will  last you must learn to enjoy yourself  what did you know about vacations  go java go job huh  the trip isn't about the destination  it's about the journey  who will be declared rulers of the beach  ruler  everybody limbo  [Music]  who's next try not to lose a hand it's  kind of a thing in our family  [Music]  it's a it's a i'm not saying it it's a  snack  [Music]  so  [Music]  bye